Okay, so solving
successfully finished,
and we've got the results.
If you had any trouble
solving this problem,
then you should go into
Options in the Solver
and select that you want to
edit the length of solution time
and increase it
past 100 seconds.
The LibreOffice Solver is
not incredibly powerful,
so it may need more time
to find the solution.
We do recommend that if
you have access to Excel,
that you use Excel instead for
integer optimization problems,
because Excel is a
little bit better
with integer optimization.
However, you probably got
the solution just fine.
So you'll want to go ahead
and click Keep Result.
So now, we can take a
look at our solution.
So we've got the
objective of 4.46.
This is not particularly
interpretable,
until you remember that
what our objective is,
is the total of all departments
percent of target allocation
hours reached.
So the best possible number
that we could get here
would be 5, if
every department had
100% of their target
allocation hours reached.
So we've got 4.46.
So let's go up and take
a look at the solution.
So we're giving ophthalmology
a total of four operating
rooms per week, which
is 32 weekly hours,
or 81% of their target.
We're giving
gynecology 14, which
is 112 weekly hours,
95% of their target.
We're giving oral surgery
two, and as we see,
the constraints restricted
us so that we only
gave oral surgery
operating rooms on Tuesdays
and Thursdays.
This is 80% of the target.
We gave otolaryngology
three operating rooms
and general surgery
23 operating rooms,
getting 91% and 97% of their
target allocation hours.
So suppose that you were the
operating room manager, who
knows integer optimization.
In practice, what would happen
is that you would go off
and you would
design what we just
did here in the recitation.
You would have this
optimization model
for operating room
scheduling in the hospital.
You'd solve it.
You'd find the optimal solution.
And you'd come back and present
it to the surgical departments.
And they'll look
at the schedule.
And all of a sudden,
they'll tell you
it doesn't work for them.
And you'll say, why not?
I incorporated everything
that you asked for.
And it's true.
You did.
But oftentimes, there are
actually other constraints
that they forgot
to tell you about.
So what would you
do in that case?
Well, you'd listen to their
additional constraints
and go back and add
them to the model.
So that's exactly
what we'll do here.
Suppose the general
surgery department
took a look at the schedule
and said, "Oh, great, we
have 23 operating
rooms per week.
That's exactly two less
than actually our maximum.
It's right in between our
minimum and our maximum.
And we're getting 97%
of our weekly target.
We think that's wonderful.
However, it's a little
bit uneven-- six
on Wednesday, three on Thursday.
Can we just have at
least four per day?"
We can do that.
So let's go up to
the minimum number
of operating rooms per day.
And for general surgery, let's
change this from zero to four.
This will help them balance
throughout the week.
And potentially, ophthalmology
will look at their schedule,
and they'll think
the same thing.
They'll think,
"Well, we actually
would prefer to balance
it throughout the week.
We want at most one
operating room per day.
We don't want to
have two on Monday.
Let's put one of those
on Thursday or Friday."
So that's OK.
We can do that too.
We just go to the maximum number
of operating rooms per day.
And for ophthalmology,
we change it to one.
Let's re-solve the model
and see what we get.
Again, we select the objective.
Go to Tools, pull
down the Solver.
It should have everything
already loaded up,
and we just get to hit Solve.
So that was quick.
Solving successfully finished.
And it looks like we actually
have exactly the same results
as we had before.
Let's hit Keep Result and
take a closer look at this.
So our objective function
stayed exactly the same.
But we were able to incorporate
the new constraints,
the new requirement that the
general surgery department have
at least four operating
rooms per day,
and that the ophthalmology
department have
at most one operating
room per day.
This means that
within the solution
we had before, there's actually
a little bit of wiggle room.
We could move some things
around without changing
the optimality of the
solution, that is,
without changing the
percent of target
that each department received.
And as you see, this
is a little more
balanced for the
ophthalmology department
and the general
surgery department.
So great-- so maybe seeing
that this was available,
then you'd go back,
you'd present it,
and general surgery
would say, well, maybe
could we have at
least five per day?
So if you went up
and changed this,
made it five all the way
across instead of four
and you solved it again,
what would happen?
You probably have
an idea already.
And this is exactly
what you were thinking.
No solution was found.
The model is infeasible.
Check limiting conditions.
So why is the model infeasible?
Well, let's take a look.
Scroll back over.
The model is infeasible
because, let's see--
so it's not because
of the minimum
and maximum weekly
department requirements,
because general surgery said
that they were willing to have
up to 25 operating
rooms per week.
However, if you look at the
weekly targets, 25 times 8
is 200.
So if we were to actually assign
general surgery five operating
rooms per day, we
would be assigning
them 200 hours per week, which
exceeds their weekly target.
And our optimization model says
we cannot exceed the weekly
targets.
So just right there,
we can tell that it's
infeasible because
of this constraint.
So let's change
this back to four.
So suppose you've come
up with a solution,
you've gone back to the
surgical departments,
you've presented your
solution, they've maybe
requested additional
changes, and we've
made those changes here.
So does this mean
that your job is done?
Well, no, not really.
Of course, you could go back
to the surgical departments
and tell them that this
is the schedule they're
going to have every week.
But I bet if did that,
you'd hear some complaints.
Let's go into our solution and
take a closer look to see why.
So for example, let's look at
the ophthalmology department.
In our solution,
we're assigning them
four operating rooms per week.
That gives them 32
weekly hours, which
is 81% of their target
allocation hours.
If you assigned the schedule to
ophthalmology every week, then
they would never
get more than 81%
of their target
allocation hours.
And over time, this would
lead to a real shortage.
The reason why we never
assign them more than four
in our optimization model is
because their weekly target
number of hours was 39.4.
If we had assigned them
five operating rooms,
it would be giving
them 40 hours per week,
which exceeds their
weekly target.
So the way our optimization
model is set up,
we will never give
them more than four
operating rooms per week.
But if you were
the OR manager, you
would realize that this
is actually something
that we should be a little
more flexible about.
Perhaps you would
consider giving them
five operating rooms
one week, or maybe
five operating rooms every
two weeks out of the month.
This is feasible because
we have extra operating
rooms on Thursday and Friday,
as you can see down here.
Plus, it seems like it's a more
efficient and fair solution.
Yes, although they do
exceed their weekly target
by 0.6 hours, it means that
on the weeks when they only
get to have 81% of
their target allocation,
they know that the
next week, they'll
be able to make up for it.
So it seems like a more
fair solution, as well as
a more efficient solution.
By combining the power
of integer optimization
with the understanding and
flexibility of human judgment,
you really get the
best of both worlds.